you don't think they have your best
interest in mind
hell no bro now the thieves have gotten
so brazen
they just go in and get whatever they
want and leave right every day
every day how does it feel being in the
city
recall gavin newsom though huh oh yeah
this guy sucks
not really tinder over here what do you
think is going on man you think we're
getting played somehow
yeah and one cop told me
do not trust the city's numbers of crime
the biggest fear state i've seen society
downtown san francisco
golden gate bridge very beautiful city
san francisco
but in this video we're going to talk
about san francisco during the pandemic
which is well
i can't say the most beautiful
environment quite a few
interesting odd and not so
uh amazing things going on at the moment
so we're gonna go downtown
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you what i'm
talking about i'm going to
explain what's going on as a resident in
the city
and well just document history i think
it's an amazing time
to document the life cycle of the city
and hope that it's never like this again
okay here we go
okay here we are guys downtown
very quiet place as you can see this is
saturday
but midweek has been like this also and
so i just want to touch on some a few
points
observations i've had by living here
my wife and i moved back to the u.s
didn't plan on staying but uh
well kova does interesting things to
people's lives so
we're here living in the city lived here
before
was gone for four years and i want to go
into some of the
some of the main topics here that i've
observed
during my time here in san francisco the
first thing i would say would be fear
there is like if the goal is to make
people scared
uh well mission accomplished that's for
sure
there's a lot of fear pulsating through
the society here so for example
you know i'm around nobody right now so
i'm not wearing a mask but outside
uh everyone's wearing a mask for the
most part and especially when they get
close
and so you know you put up your mask
and literally um you know i could be
here
someone's over there we both have masks
on
and they're they're doing this they're
they're they're going away from you and
just this look down
just look down this this paranoid
vibe so of all the places i've been in
the world 85 countries to be exact i
lived over season four
this is uh
been the biggest fear state i've seen
society
in and i'm i'm comparing with you know
afghan tajikistan border 2002
when they're uh drug lords getting
heroin
over the uh over the river and the the
tajik troops and the russian troops were
hunkered in
and honestly society in that part of the
world
had less anxiety and fear in it
than san francisco during coven i get
the
seriousness of this pandemic
i understand a lot of people's lives are
at risk but what i don't understand is
the fact that
you know we're in this together we don't
have to be so
um just scared of each other i mean it's
even gotten to the point on hiking
trails my wife doesn't want to go on the
trail behind our house because
people look at you like literally a
threat
and you know that's with distance and a
mask on
so pooping anywhere is basically legal
because there's no enforcement for
defecating
on the street i'm not trying to gross
you out here that's why i blurted out
but i just want to show you that
feces in urine all over the place down
here so the city decided to be a great
idea because of kobe
kovet to shut down all the bathrooms
so if you're gonna try to use the
restroom say i think california pizza
kitchen is open
for takeout if you want to use the
restroom not happening
coffee shop not happening so they're
pretty much uh
no no restrooms in in the in the center
of a major city i mean there might be a
few public ones
i can't imagine what those look like so
nowhere to go to the bathroom because of
covid
this is market street and over here to
the left is cvs
for those that don't know it's a
drugstore and years back
a few years back prop 47 came into law
which basically uh
made it a misdemeanor instead of a
felony to steal up to 950 dollars
worth of whatever from say a cvs
walgreens any store
and so what's going on now is uh since
the crime has increased in the city
the cops are very busy with that you
have people going in
to these stores every day of the week so
the walgreens where i live
every day of the week they say people
are going in
and stealing so they grab up to 950
worth or whatever
put it in a bag walk out now here's
where it gets very interesting and
almost
unbelievable if the employee says
anything
to the criminal uh stop or tries to stop
them or
tries to confiscate the stolen goods
the employee will get fired this is what
i've told at walgreens now i don't want
to show any of these people on
at my local walgreens they're all
fantastic great people but
they can't be on camera we're now in a
society where looting is
incentivized the da's not punishing
people
for these lower level crimes so the cops
are catching people
they're back on the street the next day
catch it and get catch them again back
on the street
you do it enough times and they become
they become demoralized
where they don't really bother with it
everyone just looks the other way now
the thieves have gotten so brazen
they've actually they actually can steal
go to the front counter and try to
return without a receipt because they
never bought anything
and try to get cash back okay
so what does this do to society what
does this do to the mentality of these
people
working at these shops during the cove
at times they're the ones being exposed
everything
they're not making a ton of money at
walgreens or cvs
and anyone can just walk in and take you
know and they can't
they can't even look at the person
they're instructed by their
employers not to even look at the thief
and because of this
crime is on the up big time
because there are no consequences who
would have thought if you don't enforce
this stuff that uh
that it would actually get worse instead
of better
but they can they just go in and get
whatever they want and leave right
every day every day i want i do
agree you can't stop them yeah you can
or can't
no stopping those though no ah man
so the employees are upset i'm sure
yeah we call the police every day what
are the police there what is the police
they come they come okay but
can't do much huh later later
i'm sorry man this is ridiculous
what what a crazy world huh yeah like
how is this possible
like we're told you can go in and take
things and then
and then leave and no consequences
oh yeah yeah you're infringing on my
rights i'm allowed to take 950 dollars
with
whatever wow that's some great logic
all right bro what's your name moses
moses
peter i'm just gonna take 950
or whatever okay so it's it's
it's honestly that insane that's it's
not a joke i'm not making this stuff
you'd think
you'd think this should be made up but
no so
you heard it from the man and it's
really been hard to get people to talk i
haven't wanted to push it because
the walgreens in my neighborhood such
sweet people such nice people and
they're like
really some of the coolest to people to
people to talk to these days during the
pandemic they just
they're just real the psychology behind
you know not being able to stop people
from stealing
where you work day in day out
has got to be heavy and no one's
representing these people that's for
sure
nice civil store some jack johnson
playing
you know but hey take what you want
so i'm not trying to be hard on the cops
because the guy said the cops come
and they don't really do anything and
they've been i think their hands are
tied
these days i don't know if there's been
actual defunding but there's a lot of
talk
and the cops from the ones i've spoken
to just i i talk to ones on the street
sometimes obviously they're not going to
be on camera
these days they're highly demoralized
and one cop told me he said
do not trust the numbers how about that
do not trust the city's numbers of crime
and okay that that sounds not credible
because i just said some guy told me
that some cop told me that
sort of like when people say sources
said you know all most mainstream
media always uses sources said which
means absolutely nothing
but this is honestly from my just
talking with people
uh and trying to understand this place
right now so
yeah cops like don't trust the numbers
crime's way up
i said why don't you quit you're
demoralized your job's sucking way more
he said a couple years i'm out of here
going to retire counting every day down
so i hope not all cops are feeling that
way at the moment
because i've been to places where
there is no honest policing
and uh the police don't have much
control of society that's not a healthy
society that's
not a lot of fun uh
because there's some other force that
comes in and fills the vacuum
we obviously want good policing that's
the goal but
uh demoralized cops in the city
not healthy coming up on tenderloin now
tenderloin's up here a little bit more
we'll poke in a bit tenderloin is
notorious for
just being a little bit of a rougher
neighborhood actually a lot rougher
so what the city's also been doing is
putting a lot of homeless in
uh hotels because there are no tourists
here right now
so the city's been saying you know let's
let's put these people in hotels
i forget what the program's called uh so
thousands of homeless
are in hotels with that said there's
still a ton on the streets
and a lot don't want to go in the hotels
because i think they're rules that go
along with it
or on the streets if you're an attic
you can use your needles do whatever you
want
power of the dead idols which you
worship the idols
of money the idols of fame
the idols of sex the idols of adultery
anything that you put before god you are
making a god
humble yourself he's a great speaker
here's a statistic a san francisco
statistic for you
last year 699
overdose deaths in the city and 235
covet deaths so what's that basically
three times
as many overdoses as kovac does
they really got some bad cop cars look
at these things
they're beat up all right
so here's wes westfield popular downtown
mall and the interesting thing is
is the the city decided that that this
is cool now they say i think
30 or something i'm not sure the
percentage but
i've been in here and it's been pretty
busy i don't think they're really
monitoring it
but restaurants outdoor dining
which there have been no studies in the
city
claiming that that's spreading kovid are
closed so all the the beautiful
soulful businesses of this city
have been uh well just choked out
hello
you can't do the outside thing at a
restaurant
but you can walk inside to a mall look
i'm all for this being opened i'm not
saying shut this down i just feel like
it's hard
judgment on the restaurants we got
what's going on here
recall go what's going on here
recall gavin newsom though huh hell yeah
this guy sucks
get him out french laundry they're just
that the whole thing
and the guy is so into himself and his
own ascendance to
uh the president oh yeah he's just in
more corruption
do you think he's got a chance no
yeah it seems like a lot of our
politicians don't really have any of our
interests in mind
you haven't yet yeah it doesn't matter
right this is a bipartisan effort
all the way oh really oh god yes i'm a
dem
san francisco born and raised i believe
that he
is bringing california down
intentionally
intentionally destroying small business
because yeah that's true
these closures have been arbitrary the
westfield mall behind you is open
right now all day long it's just over
there
yeah restaurants are all costco you name
it these big box places they're the big
business
they're going to last they want to wipe
out entrepreneurship they don't want the
middle class
they don't want them dependent on the
big guys
okay people who are trying to make a
living raise their families take care of
themselves
do what's right they're taxpayers too
they're wiping out an entire tax base
i'll tell you that much
right as well and um it's showing you
know where the pension
where's the pension money gonna come
from keep saying they're gonna tax the
billionaires
well they're all leaving california
we've had it
as it is in this state i mean it's so
real what's going on it's just people
need to wake
up we need to wake up
what does californians need to do right
now because it's getting quite
ridiculous where it's legalized to go
steal up to 950 dollars
the the security guards can't even stop
them they're not even allowed to
remember
that we are the base of the culture we
are the people we make it happen or we
let people
stomp all over us so we can't complain
it's up to us
and the lockdowns right now these are
indefinite from what i know right now
indefinite oh yeah they told us that
didn't they and as a matter of fact san
francisco has never gone below 22
and i see your availability for uh well
over a month it's been probably about
six weeks
since yes
all right so how many how many uh
signatures do you guys have well it's
over 1.1 million
how many do you need 1.5 wow
i was thinking of doing the same thing
but here i'm supporting i really was
this guy
he stole his soul you don't think they
have your best interest in mind
so guys i didn't expect to run into this
i i thought it was going to be empty
down here and it's actually there's some
life
and there's and there's some real p
there's some real people
it feels nice to look at people in my
neighborhood nobody's looking at each
other right
they've fallen asleep it's they're all
scared here they got the devil's fear
they got so much fun bro they shine up
thank you
good luck in everything you do wow guys
so
just a conversation is like uh i got
chills
because it hasn't happened it's not
happening in this city but downtown
it actually is so here we have
anti-abortion
and again my content guys for those that
watch
my videos i show what i see
you make your decision i'm not telling
you what to think
so tension for sure she said if they
rape us we got a [ __ ] choice
i love this about america is that
the peaceful protest peaceful protest is
beautiful
we would have died we would have got
shot look at this are they getting shot
the police aren't leading
are they getting paid no no it looks it
looks chill
and we were just as peaceful as they
were what you got you got you guys
walked down here the same way
like the same thing happened with you
guys down the street
okay i did protest in a couple of
different things oh it's for myself yeah
you're supposed to i am i'm posting all
this yeah
yeah yeah yeah how does it feel being in
the city
this is obviously a tense issue
tense issue you're gonna walk get back
to the theme of the video
well this is sort of the theme of the
video covet during uh
san francisco during covet times
all right what's your name i'm jason
jason yes so what you're saying you were
just saying what
i was saying that has been the
apocalypse since march of
2020 and the world is starting to come
to an end all of a sudden
and it's been ghost town in san
francisco it's very unusual to see
nobody really out here like that
right kind of have a little bit of life
you know it's kind of like a protest
going on
yeah that was just even if you don't
agree with it or you agree with whatever
it's just good to see like people
you know what i mean he's representing
seeing people again
so what's crime doing around here do you
have any beat on that do you know what's
going on
as far as prime this is the tenderloin
even though it's
tenderloin there's nothing really tender
over here
but uh it's not it's not for the soft
people huh
people from my neighborhood are not
coming down here that's for sure right
exactly but i'll tell you what people
are cooler here right now for some
reason than over in my neighborhood
right i'm out of the city a little
everyone's scared of [ __ ] of each other
it sucks
all right i'm from kansas city you're
from kansas city
what's that like kansas city it's a lot
more
i would say it's very different as far
as like the whole epidemic
because they're not really shut down or
anything like that i just have to wear a
mask
you know make sure they're being safe
but everything out there is pretty much
still open
california new york everything's shut
down so in kansas city it's just
sort of normal life right now yeah
normal life right now what do you
think's going on man do you think we're
getting played somehow or what what's
your thoughts on that
or who knows i do i do definitely think
we are getting played
look at the mini mini bike here man
right
damn what's up man
so what's going in the the tenderloin i
heard there was like uh i think it was a
week ago or two weeks there was like a
five people shot down here did you hear
about that i did it
okay yeah yeah
i mean i've noticed crimes up everywhere
yeah
you know about mr said what happened you
know what happened
no i just i just saw a report on an app
crime map killing each other our police
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it wasn't the
police that
some guy just went loose with his gun so
do you do you notice the homelessness on
the up here or down or even or what
um i would say if the epidemic happened
it
definitely went up okay and it was worth
it was bad before
yeah you got the beach
floodlight you guys are living it up
the sun the music the beer gosh
you're not you're not freaking out on
life
see you guys
here we have city hall nice little
playground
and over here we have
a tent city
there are a few of these around the city
but i believe this is a place where they
set up
tents and bathrooms and places for
homeless to be
off the streets but sort of on the
street at the same time
and this city is just it's just rife
with juxtapositions it's
some of the richest people in the world
and then
some of the poorest
maybe not the world but in the country
for sure like some of the more
down and outs uh people hard on their
luck
uh and then some of the
some of the wealthiest it's weird
uh city's got all sorts of problems
and you know i think the pandemic just
like they're always here but it it put
the spotlight
on everything it gave it a 10x
uh feel and so when things open up you
know say the vaccine goes through the
population the restaurants open back up
again
and uh the lights are on basically right
and we have all the business activity
and all the
all the life on the streets again maybe
this problem quiets down again but i do
feel like it's like a
like a loud refrigerator which means
it'll always be humming in the
background
and it needs to be addressed there's
something fundamentally wrong
here right now with the pandemic and
just the
the dynamic of this place
retail space plenty of it
across the street empty
ecuador coffee sounds a good place
warfield
a lot of jesus people down here a lot of
recall gavin newsom people and some
street music this is fantastic been
missing this
thank you for being out here we need
street music so bad
like mrs stuff oh thank you
yeah take care good luck
here we are in pacific heights one of
the wealthiest neighborhoods in the city
and while that video did not go as
according to plan
i was going to show you what i've been
feeling here which is this
pervasive fear in society
and it was actually more people out
out and about and smiling and looking at
one another
in the center of the city than in my
neighborhood that's for sure
oh well it was interesting
good to see what this city is doing
right now you can see it's low
it's on its knees a bit so let's
uh let's hope this place turns around
in time because it's
it could go worse but let's hope not
okay until the next one oh and if you
want to support this channel i have a
patreon page
down below a lot more videos from
around the world and i'll be doing much
more here in the states
in the uh well the upcoming year okay
thanks for coming along
until the next one
you